hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live die Zukunft ist elektrisch das
wollen die deutschen Autobauer aktuell
bei der IAA mobility-messe in München
zeigen das haben wir schon öfter gehört
oder ob die deutschen da wirklich noch
eine Rolle spielen das stellen nämlich
auch einige Experten in Frage zwar
möchte die Bundesregierung 15 Millionen
E-Autos bis 2030 auf die Straße bringen
wie sie das in der bisherigen
Geschwindigkeit schaffen soll das weiß
aber keiner so recht denn aktuell
aktuelle Zahlen sind nur 1,5 Millionen
E-Autos in Deutschland unterwegs wann
soll er kommen der Durchbruch in Sachen
eMobilität der Kanzler verspricht bei
der Eröffnung gestern klimaneutrale
Mobilität in Deutschland und vor allem
auch aus Deutschland aber genau das ist
in Gefahr der Marktführer von
e-autoherstellern im ersten Halbjahr
kommt aus China und hat nun auch
Deutschland ins Visier genommen der
Autobauer beyond hat eine größere
Ausstellungsfläche auf der mess e in
München als Volkswagen der Europa-Chef
von bey die sagte dem Handelsblatt
Deutschland als Herz der Autoindustrie
sei der wichtigste Markt in Europa
die chinesischen Hersteller haben
inzwischen einen technologischen
Vorsprung bei der akuproduktion und sie
bieten eben auch mehr bezahlbare Autos
an ist das noch aufzuholen oder ist die
deutsche Autoindustrie am Ende das ist
heute unser Thema und ihr könnt Fragen
dazu stellen per Mail oder direkt mit
kommentieren im Stream denn wir haben
uns spannende Gäste eingeladen es geht
jetzt am Anfang los mit zwei Gästen
gleichzeitig bei uns ist Professor Dr
Helena wispert sie ist Professorin für
Automobilwirtschaft an der Ostfalia
Hochschule in Wolfsburg sie sagt wir
leben in einer Branche von Ankündigung
ihre Kritik und wir sprechen mit Simon
Schütz er ist der Sprecher des Verbands
der Automobilindustrie er sagt es müssen
Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden
damit Deutschland international
wettbewerbsfähig ist hier sind die
beiden heute unsere Gäste hallo schön
dass Sie da sind
schönen guten Abend schön dass ich da
sein darf der Kanzler hatte gestern die
Messe eröffnet und sich auch zu der
Konkurrenz aus dem Ausland geäußert wir
hören mal direkt zusammen in den Ton
rein
in den 80er Jahren hieß es jetzt
überrollen japanische Autos alle anderen
merkte 20 Jahre später waren es Autos
made in Korea heute sind es vermeintlich
chinesische Elektroautos
ja auch außerhalb Deutschlands werden
gute Autos gebaut und entwickelt schön
dass so viele internationale Hersteller
und Zulieferer hier in München sind
willkommen und zugleich steht doch die
internationale Wettbewerbsfähigkeit des
autolandes Deutschlands völlig außer
Frage
Kanzler Scholz stellt die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit von Deutschland da
also nicht in Frage wir fangen an mit
Ihnen Frau Professor Dr wispert sehen
Sie denn dass wir noch Chancen haben auf
dem Markt um gegen China wirklich auf
dem e-automat anzukommen wo das jetzt so
eine große Konkurrenz ist und die jetzt
aktuell auch wirklich Marktführer schon
sind
ja also die deutschen Autobauer die
nehmen jetzt wirklich jeden Euro in die
Hand und investieren insbesondere in die
ja batteriezeitfertigung um diesen
großen Kostenblock der Batterie unter
Kontrolle zu bekommen und habe eben
jetzt für die nächsten Jahre auch eine
umfassendes Produktportfolio an
Elektroautos angekündigt das Zitat von
Bundeskanzler Scholz das ist ja eine
ähnliche Situation ist wie mit dem
Markteintritt der japanischen Autobauer
oder der koreanischen Autobauer in der
Vergangenheit ist in dem in der Hinsicht
ja nicht ganz eins zu eins übertragbar
auf die neuen chinesischen Wettbewerber
weil die haben einen großen Vorteil
gegenüber der den heimischen Autobauern
die haben die Batterie quasi die volle
Kontrolle über die Kosten wie weit die
sie hatten es eben gesagt dass der wird
bald der größte Elektroauto Anbieter der
Welt sein da wird Tesla dieses Jahr
überholen und die kommen aus der
batterieherstellung also das war mal ein
batter iehersteller also die haben
diesen größten kostenlos bei den E-Autos
nämlich die Batterie voll unter
Kontrolle
die Chinesen also wirklich ganz weit
vorne Herr schützt sie stehen ein also
für die Automobilindustrie sind der
Sprecher können Sie uns erklären wie das
sein kann dass ich die deutschen
Autobauer immer ganz weit vorne sich da
haben so den Rang ablaufen lassen
also da würde ich widersprechen dass wir
uns den Rang haben ablaufen lassen fakt
ist dass wir hier auf dieser IAA
mobility eine Leistungsshow der
deutschen Autoindustrie leben wir werden
über 300 Neuheiten präsentiert in den
nächsten Jahren bis Ende 24 wird es
weltweit 170 e Modelle deutscher
Hersteller geben da ist für jeden was
dabei fakt ist aber auch das ist richtig
das haben sie angesprochen dass er die
Kollegin angesprochen die Chinesen haben
einen Vorteil sie haben einen
Kostenvorteil sie haben billige
Energiepreise und sie haben den Zugang
zu den günstigen Rohstoffen der für die
Batterien wichtig ist und da muss man
einfach sehen dass Deutschland hier an
den Rahmenbedingungen arbeiten muss wir
brauchen wettbewerbsfähige Energiepreise
und wir brauchen auch den Zugang zu
Rohstoffen wir setzen uns schon seit
langem dafür ein dass mehr
rohstoffpartnerschaften mehr Energie
Partnerschaften mehr
handelspartnerschaften abgeschlossen
werden nicht geben nur das Beispiel mehr
Kultur an dem die EU schon über 20 Jahre
verhandelt das sind Lücken die da
entstehen die dann von den Chinesen
eingenommen werden umso mehr gilt es
jetzt diese Rahmenbedingungen zu
schaffen und ich glaube wenn Politik und
Industrie hier jetzt die richtigen
Entscheidungen treffen und Hand in Hand
gehen dann wird auch die Zukunft der
deutschen Autoindustrie gehören neben
dem Kostenvorteil sind aber die Chinesen
vor allem eins unfassbar innovativ und
inzwischen ist hier die Gegenwart
elektrisch eben nicht nur die Zukunft in
China werden die früher beliebten
deutschen verbrennerautos ausgemustert
wir schauen gemeinsam rein in einen
Beitrag von Luca Simonis
mit Schleife und Blumenstrauß in China
ist der e-autokauf ein Event passend
dazu auch mit Überraschung im Kofferraum
das Elektroauto ist ist ein Lifestyle
Produkt das erweiterte zu Hause für
Menschen in China jedes zweite Auto mit
Elektroantrieb weltweit fährt auf
chinesischen Straßen stark vertreten
sind die Chinesen jetzt auch auf der IAA
in München die Autos hier sind oft klein
und 10.000 € billiger als vergleichbare
deutsche Modelle wir merken dass die
Chinesen in den letzten Jahren ah das
Auto bauen gelernt haben sie haben eine
erhebliche Geschwindigkeit wenn es darum
geht digitalisierte Lösungen ins
Fahrzeug zu bringen Batteriezellen
Halbleiter Dauermagnete fast alles was
ein Auto teuer macht kann in China
vergleichsweise günstig produziert
werden mit Rohstoffen meist aus dem
eigenen Land deutsche Hersteller müssen
die meist teuer importieren der
e-automat wächst schnell und das heißt
umkämpft bis 2022 dominierte Tesla den
Markt vor den Herstellern und aus China
und VW und BMW in diesem Jahr könnte die
Marktführer werden
unter den zehn meistverkauften
Elektroautos in China kein einziges
deutsches Modell deutsche Autobauer
fahren auf dem chinesischen Automarkt
mittlerweile hinterher bald auch in
Europa
kein einziges Modell mehr beliebt in
China von den deutschen Autos wir haben
es gerade gehört viele Ressourcen die
die E-Autos brauchen die müssen deutsche
Firmen erst teuer importieren Herr
schützt die Frage an Sie hängen sie
deshalb so sehr am Verbrenner hin die
Industrie deshalb so lange am Verbrenner
weil einfach sonst nicht genug Gewinn
bleibt
nein ich glaube natürlich verdient die
Industrie jetzt noch Geld mit dem
Verbrenner denn dieses Geld ist ja genau
das Geld was wir investieren in den
nächsten Jahren bis zu 27 investieren
wir 250 Milliarden in Forschungen
Entwicklung vor allem in die Elektro
Mobilität und 130 Milliarden in den
Umbau von Werken und das Geld muss
natürlich auch erwirtschaftet werden und
das tun wir gerade und dann muss man
sehen mit der Zeit ja wenn die Skalen
Effekte wenn die Massenproduktion
losgeht und das tut sie gerade dann
werden auch die Preise sind
ich habe noch eine Nachfrage es gibt
nämlich einen Kommentar bei uns aus dem
Stream da schreibt ein User oder
kommentiert deutsche Autos sind zu teuer
und die Folgekosten eine Abzocke wenn
ihre Autos was ja der Fakt ist teurer
sind als die chinesische Konkurrenz dann
wird das so ja auch nicht oder
naja man muss hier auch eine ehrliche
Analyse machen in China wird die
Autoindustrie massiv vom Staat
subventioniert und nein das ist kein
Aufruf zu Subventionen das wollen wir
nicht wir wollen einfach dass die
Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden
international ist ein massiver
Standortwettbewerb aktuell im Gange ja
wir haben in China eine Industrie die
massiv von Staat unterstützt wird wir
haben in den USA den Inflation reduction
Act der Investitionen in die USA Lok und
wir haben in Europa meist eine Reaktion
auf auf Krisen und auf Herausforderungen
mit Regulierung mit Bürokratie und davon
müssen wir uns lösen wir müssen uns
entfesseln wir müssen den Innovationen
und da sind wir ganz vorne ja die
deutschen Unternehmen sind bei
Innovationen ganz vorne mit dabei und
das müssen wir jetzt auf die Straße
bringen und da sind wir wieder bei dem
Rahmenbedingungen das ist ein
Zusammenspiel von Politik und Industrie
und ähm wer die deutsche Autoindustrie
jetzt abschreibt der der wird sich noch
wundern denn ich kann Ihnen versichern
das wird nicht der Fall sein
Herr Schütz kritisiert die
Rahmenbedingungen in Deutschland Frau
Professor Dr wispert sie haben die
Kritik gehört sehen Sie das dass wenn
sich die Rahmenbedingungen sowie Herr
schützt das fordert ändern würden sehen
Sie dass wir dann wirklich
konkurrenzfähig sind oder wo sehen Sie
die Probleme
also wir sehen es an den Produkten an
den Modellen die jetzt im Markt sind und
das sind eben eher ja größere SUVs also
am ab dem mittelklassensegment ein
kleines ein Auto im Kleinwagensegment in
Europa eine E-Auto im Kleinwagensegment
im in Europa zu produzieren ist heute
noch nicht wirtschaftlich darstellbar
und deswegen also die meisten wir haben
es bei vor zum Beispiel gesehen der Ford
Focus ist ausgelaufen in Köln und es
kommt jetzt eben ein größerer ja höher
30 positionierte SUV an seine Stelle und
ähm das ist eben dadurch bedingt dass
eben diese Produktionskosten in Europa
eben höher sind als z.B in China für die
Elektroautos wir werden aber in den
nächsten Jahren da eben in der
Reduzierung der Kosten sehen was als ich
aber schneller ändern wird ist der
Marktpreis weil sie hat uns eben in den
Beitrag ja auch erwähnt das
Wettbewerbsfeld wird zum Teil den
Marktpreis bestimmen und die
chinesischen Autobauer die steigen jetzt
oder sind bis jetzt
den gleichen Preisniveau eingestiegen
werden das aber in Zukunft eben dann
auch unterbieten und ja dann müssen die
heimischen Autobauer sich daran anpassen
also wir haben früher eine Preisparität
also das ein E-Auto ja eigentlich zum
gleichen Preis angeboten werden wird wie
ein vergleichbar Verbrenner also die
Preisqualität wird schneller da sein als
die kostenparität also da werden dann
eben weniger ja die Marge singt das
werden weniger Gewinne mit den E-Autos
in naher Zukunft gemacht werden als mit
den verbrennerfahrzeugen auch wenn Sie
einen das ist auch immer noch nach wie
vor ja vielleicht dazu noch zur
Einordnung also 40% der
Produktionskosten eines e-Autos sind
immer noch die Batterie und dieser große
Kostenblock das ist eben ja jetzt der
Punkt wo viele dran ansetzen und die
chinesischen Autobauer haben da eben
diesen Kostenvorteil wir haben darüber
gesprochen und geben den dann auch in
Zukunft an die Kunden und Kundinnen als
preisverteil weiter über die Batterie
sprechen wir gleich auch noch mal
ausführlich ich möchte aber auch eine
Nachfrage durch einen Kommentar an Sie
aus dem Stream stellen hier kommentiert
ein User eine Userin ich für meinen Teil
kaufe kein E-Auto aus China dann lieber
einen deutschen Verbrenner woher kommt
das diese Verbrenner Nostalgie dieses
hängen am Verbrenner in Deutschland
wurde einfach lang genug von der
Autoindustrie Werbung dafür gemacht oder
wurde das lange genug auch in den
Verbrenner investiert wo sind da die
Gründe für Sie
also die deutsche Automobilindustrie der
Volk der basiert ja auf der
basiert ja auf der verbrennertechnologie
deswegen also sie ist ja eine sehr lange
Tradition der verbrennertechnologie und
dieser deutschen Ingenieurskunst bei der
verbrennertechnologie in Deutschland
quasi verankert und daher kommt auch zum
Teil diese Verbrenner Nostalgie obwohl
die Elektroautos genauso emotionalisiert
werden können aufgeladen werden können
mit Emotionen wie die Verbrenner also
die stehen dem ja weil beim Fahrgefühl
in nichts nach
nichtsdestotrotz wir sehen und Studien
die wir machen sehen da eben eine ja
jetzt eine eine stärker werden
Zurückhaltung bei den Kundinnen und
Kunden die sagen warum soll ich mir
heute ein Elektroauto anschaffen wenn
jetzt eben viele Autobauer insbesondere
die Volumen Hersteller sagen in zwei
Jahren bringen wir ein E-Auto für 25000
€ auf den Markt dann ist es eben so ja
dann warte ich eben noch mal zwei Jahre
also 2022 war ein Boom Jahr für die
Elektroautos in Deutschland und jetzt in
2023 da ist so die Stimmung ein bisschen
hat sich ein bisschen eingetrübt was das
ganze Thema E-Auto angeht kommen wir
jetzt noch mal zu dem Punkt den Sie
gerade angesprochen haben die Batterie
sie haben gesagt dass vor allem in
kostenpunkt hier im Stream lese ich
Kommentare mehrere in die Richtung die
wird die Reichweiten Problematik gelöst
die meisten E-Autos können in der Regel
die 500 km nicht garantieren also lassen
Sie uns auch darüber noch mal sprechen
nämlich über die Problematik auch der
langen Ladezeiten für Batterie wenn denn
auch da kommt Hilfe aus China wenn dazu
auch ein paar Bilder die wir zeigen
können denn chinesische Hersteller die
bieten auch einen schnellen
Batteriewechsel an das werden wir gleich
sehen und so ist das natürlich auch ein
Thema was da eine Rolle spielt und zwar
künftig kündigt China an soll auch eine
super Batterie kommen die 400 km in nur
10 Minuten aufladen soll also damit wäre
natürlich dann Reichweiten Problematik
auch gelöst Herr schützt die Frage der
an sie wie innovativ und vor allem
konkurrenzfähig ist denn Deutschland in
diesem Bereich in diesem essentiellen
Teil der Batterie
ja ich glaube das ist ein Beispiel dafür
was man hier auf der IAA mobility sieht
denn wir haben hier Autos die erreichen
jetzt schon die 600 die 700 Kilometer
Reichweite also das Thema
reichweitenangst das hat sich damit
erledigt und noch ein kleiner Punkt zu
dem was sie vorher sagten mit dem
Verbrenner und ob die Leute daran hängen
das ist auch hier mit verbunden weil die
Sprachen ja auch das Laden an natürlich
ist es auch ganz wichtig dass die Leute
das Vertrauen haben immer und überall
laden zu können und da gibt's jetzt
viele Initiativen auch von der Regierung
das muss jetzt auf den Weg gebracht
werden das genau das passiert dass man
immer und überall laden kann auch die
schnellladepunkte damit das schnelle
Laden garantiert wird und ich kann Ihnen
Garantieren ich habe hier mit vielen
Menschen gesprochen auf den open spaces
die sich die Autos anschauen da ist
genau diese Faszination und dieser
emotionale Faktor den sie eben ja auch
Ansprachen der natürlich auch Menschen
emotionalisiert für den Auto kauft und
ich kann auch aus persönlicher Erfahrung
berichten mit allen Menschen die ich
gesprochen haben die den ja dieses
diesen Schritt getraut haben auf das
E-Auto umzusteigen die sind begeistert
und wollen nicht mehr zurück und ich
glaube das ist wie so eine Art Schnee
ffekt das werden immer mehr Menschen
werden und dann wird der Wandel sich
auch entsprechend verschnellern
Frau Professor Wisper sind sie da
genauso optimistisch also wir haben zwar
auch Zulieferer die natürlich eine
Batterietechnologie eine Rolle spielen
wie Bosch z.B sind die aber auch
wirklich konkurrenzfähig überleben die
das wenn China jetzt kommt mit einer
super Batterie
auf der IAA wurden jetzt eben auch von
den deutschen Autobauern diese ja neuen
Reichweiten jetzt angekündigt und
insbesondere auch sehr kurze Ladezeiten
also die stehen da im nächsten nach also
die Chor werden auch kommen
grundsätzlich ist es so
klar die Batterie wir werden auch in
Zukunft Reichweiten realistisch dann
eben an 500 km rankommen also das ist
der Stand der Technik heute und dann
eben in Zukunft dann eben auch 700 km
der große Punkt des Ladens wir haben
jetzt in den also die ersten Kundinnen
und Kunden die Elektroautos in
Deutschland sich angeschafft haben das
sind in erster Linie die Kundinnen und
Kunden die zu Hause laden können oder
die eben im Unternehmen bei der Arbeit
laden können aber für den massenhochlauf
müssen wir eben jetzt auch ja müssen die
Elektroautos eben auch für Kundinnen und
Kunden interessant sein die quasi
Laternen Parker sind die eben nicht über
die Möglichkeit verfügen eine eigene
Ladepunkt zu installieren also quasi zum
Beispiel in den Städten wohnen und ja
noch nicht meine eigenen Parkplatz quasi
haben und da gilt es jetzt wirklich dass
Elektroauto fahren und Fahrer sich auch
zu 100% ihr Mobilität auf 100%
öffentliche Laden Infrastruktur planen
können und da sind wir heute in
Deutschland noch nicht
so die Einschätzung von Frau Professor
Dr Helena wispert und der Sprecher des
Verbands der Automobilindustrie Simon
Schütz vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit heute
danke schön
und wir können jetzt an dieser Stelle
auch noch mal das Thema ein bisschen
größer denken denn wir haben uns jetzt
spannend eingeladen eine Ökonomen bei
uns ist Professor Ulrike mal wenn dir
sie ist Wirtschaftsweise sie berät die
Bundesregierung in Wirtschaftsfragen sie
es Professoren an der Universität in
Berkley in Kalifornien und jetzt heute
mein Gast schön dass Sie da sind hallo
ja sehr gerne schauen wir jetzt
gemeinsam am Anfang jetzt auch noch mal
zusammen auf die Zahlen auf die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung der
Autoindustrie in Deutschland weil darum
soll es gleich in unserem Gespräch gehen
denn während die Inlandsproduktion von
Autos in Deutschland zwar in den letzten
zehn Jahren gesunken es um 35% gesunken
es interessanterweise aber der Umsatz
der Branche enorm gestiegen
42%, also interessant dass das hier so
zwei unterschiedliche Zahlen sind die
sich gegenüber stehen und da direkt am
Anfang die Frage an Sie wie passt das
zusammen also auf der einen Seite eben
Produktion gesunken aber Umsatz
gestiegen
ja in insgesamt ist die deutsche
Autoindustrie ja nicht nur deswegen eine
Stütze der deutschen Wirtschaft gewesen
seit vielen Jahren und Jahrzehnten weil
sie im Inland Gewinne erzielt hat und
Absatz erzielt hat sondern auch weil sie
immer im Ausland stark gewesen ist als
zum Beispiel China in die WTO
eingetreten ist und viele Länder
einschließlich der Vereinigten Staaten
unter dem sogenannten China
schockelliten haben haben wir das in
Deutschland überhaupt nicht wir haben
einen Absatzmarkt entdeckt und haben
halt ganz geschickt die verschiedenen
ähm die verschiedenen
Geschäftsbeziehungen zu Ländern genutzt
und dann neue Absatzmärkte zu schaffen
und das hoffe ich auch in der Tat dass
das ähm in die Zukunft blicken weiter
der deutschen Autoindustrie helfen wird
es wird vielleicht nicht mehr China sein
aber es wird andere Länder geben wo wir
neue Absatzmärkte entdecken können
und produzieren wir dann noch in
Deutschland wir was denken sie
ja ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen
also man muss die zwei Dinge zunächst
mal auseinanderhalten
bislang wurde halt die cashkauf
Verbrennermotor sehr genutzt gut genutzt
wenn der deutschen Autoindustrie sie hat
es geschafft sich dadurch eine ziemlich
große Kriegskasse anzusammeln von
Mitteln die jetzt in hoffentlich
zukunftsorientiertere Investitionen
hineinfließen können und in insofern ist
bislang Deutschland als Produktionsort
nach wie vor wichtig gewesen damit es
auch so bleibt wenn der Wandel hin zum
Elektroauto noch vollständiger vollzogen
ist dazu bedarf ist natürlich einer
neuen Geschwindigkeit was die Produktion
von Batterien das Nachdenken über
Ladestation wie gerade eben angesprochen
bitte und wir haben vor drei Wochen hier
in dieser Sendung mit ihnen über
zukunftsindustrie geredet gehört für sie
in Deutschland die Autoindustrie da
überhaupt noch dazu
ja die Autoindustrie insgesamt gehört
sicherlich dazu die Autoindustrie hat
einen enormen Wandel erlebt weg von dem
wie eben beschrieben toll designten in
das von Ingenieuren hergestellt und
Verbrennerauto zu einem ja im
Wesentlichen Computer auch Rädern und da
wird halt manchmal wird man zu dem
Schluss dass die Deutschen da vielleicht
diesen Wandel verschlafen haben aber
wenn sie ihn schaffen wenn sie noch
schaffen werden dann ist auf jeden Fall
Teil einer sehr Zukunft orientierten
Industrie die Frage ist kommen wir da
jetzt rein und ich habe ja schon gesagt
einerseits würde ich auch noch nicht den
Schwan gesagt ob die deutsche
Autoindustrie anstimmen weil es halt
schon von Management Perspektive sehr
geschickt war da jetzt noch das letzte
rauszuholen was aus dem verbrenner motor
rauszuholen ist aber ich habe manchmal
Sorgen wie vollständig der Umschwung
passiert ähm das ist ja immer so wenn es
radikale umschwinge gibt in Industrien
radikale Innovation dann sind halt die
alten Platz unintelligible oft die
allerletzten die sich darauf einlassen
und ich hoffe sehr dass das weiter
angekoppelt wird das klang ja gerade
alles der positiv aber auch dass man
dann noch einen Schritt weiter denkt
also prima dass wir jetzt alle über
Batterien Nachdenken über Elektroautos
über Reichweiten Ladestationen und wenn
das dann doch nicht klappt wenn selbst
mit der superbatterie die Reichweite
nicht genügt sollten wir vielleicht doch
noch ein bisschen rumtüfteln am
grünen Wasserstoff Motor vielleicht wird
das die Lösung sein also ich würde mir
sehr wünschen dass jetzt die
Aufgeschlossenheit da ist drüber
nachzudenken welche das Ratschen könnte
die nächste sein ja der Verband der
Automobilindustrie wir haben ihn gerade
gehört in der Form von Herrn Schütz der
war natürlich sehr positiv trotzdem gab
es hier auch ein VW Marken Chef der sich
nämlich sehr kritisch geäußert hat da
hatte das Handelsblatt das Manager
Magazin berichtet und zwar hinterher
wohl eine Brandrede weil das
e-autogeschäft so schwach laufen soll
müssen wir uns dann aber Sorge machen
wenn man sich jetzt auch der VW
Markenchef hinstellt und das das so
formuliert müssen wir uns Sorgen machen
dass der deutsche Unternehmen vielleicht
auf der Strecke wenn es nicht schnell
genug geht sogar vielleicht pleite gehen
am Ende
ja also was die Automobilindustrie
selber die großen deutschen
Automobilfirmen betrifft mache ich mir
im Augenblick nicht die größten Sorgen
sie sind jetzt halt sehr langsam in
diesen Sektor des E-Autos reingegangen
sie fangen da auch mehr so am oberen
Marktsegment an das bedeutet es gibt
mengenmäßig nicht so viele Umsätze das
könnte allerdings gewinnmargenmäßig
keine schlechte Idee sein ich denke die
haben das schon gut durchgerechnet da
habe ich eigentlich noch ziemlich großes
Vertrauen dass wir es schaffen könnten
idealerweise gebündelt damit dass wir in
Deutschland die super super Batterie
entwickeln oder das Netzwerk für
Ladestation oder die Plug und
Ladestation die dann dominiert so
ähnlich wie im Computerbereich man mit
Operationssystem dominieren kann das das
wäre dann schon die Hoffnung dass
bräuchtet ist dazu allerdings mache ich
mir schon ein wenig Sorgen um die
angegliederten Industrien die Zulieferer
die hat wirklich darauf spezialisiert
sind die Komponenten für
verbrennermotoren zu liefern im
Augenblick auch noch brauchen dass da in
den Regionen in den Firmen Umschulungen
stattfinden dass da umgeschwenkt wird
auf zukunftsorientierte Produktion da
mache ich mir ein bisschen mehr Sorgen
ob wir da vielleicht Insolvenzen und
firmenleiten sehen werden sie haben eben
auch angesprochen aus managerperspektive
war es klug eben noch oder ist es klug
das Letzte aus dem Verbrenner
rauszuquetschen ich habe hier einen
Kommentar bei uns im Stream gelesen da
schreibt ein User oder Userin die
Hybrid-Technologie von Toyota ist
deutschen Herstellern mindestens 20
Jahre voraus Tesla fährt mit Akku davon
kann Deutschland sich den Verbrenner
überhaupt noch leisten weil statt jetzt
ist er ja bei uns überall auf den
Straßen natürlich zugegen
ja in der Tat also von
managementperspektive wie sie das gerade
gesagt haben erzeugt es derzeit noch
Gewinn ist erzeugt Rekordgewinne in der
deutschen Autoindustrie wenn man mal
nicht mit b.i.d oder oder Tesla
vergleicht sondern mehr mit
vergleichbaren Firmen wie zum Beispiel
Toyota fort etc sieht man dass die
deutsche Autoindustrie recht gut da
steht das heißt aber nicht dass Sie auch
in Zukunft weiter gut da stehen wird
wenn wir uns die Börsenbewertung
anschauen dann sieht das ja von dem von
Mark Texas aus als ob man da vielleicht
ein bisschen pessimistischer ist das
also vielleicht diese
Zukunftsorientierung fehlt und das ist
da jetzt genügend Durchbrüche gibt das
zusammengearbeitet wird mit kleinen
innovativen Unternehmen die auch an
Batterien herumtüfte und die
anlagestationen herumtüfte das ist jetzt
extrem wichtig dass ich die
Autoindustrie weiter dafür öffnet
es gibt auch kritische Stimmen bei uns
im Stream auf einen ganz bestimmten
Punkt den diese E-Autos natürlich
brauchen und zwar geht es da um die
Rohstoffe Roland Vogt schreibt für die
E-Autos gibt es sowieso nicht genug
Rohstoffe das wird spätestens in vier
bis fünf Jahren zum E-Auto Gau werden so
sagt der User und gestern gab es
tatsächlich auch bei der Eröffnung der
IAA mobility ganz viele Protestaktionen
auf der Messe wo es eigentlich nämlich
auf dieser IAA mobility grundsätzlich um
Fortbewegung gehen sollte auch jenseits
des Autos deshalb heißt die mobility gab
es nun also Protestaktion so auch von
Greenpeace die sprachen von einem
enormen Energieverbrauch der Autos das
ist die Kritik der die Klimakrise treibt
dann natürlich von Ausbeutung von
Rohstoffen und greenpeace fordert und
auch andere Umwelt Organisation eine
Verkehrspolitik die Mobilität nicht
länger mit dem eigenen Auto gleichsetzt
sehen Sie denn dort eine innovative
mobilitätspolitik in Deutschland die
eben zukunftsgewand ist und auch
Klimaziele einhält sind wir da schon
das was wir uns vornehmen bis 2030 und
auch andere Ziele die man sich so steckt
kann man das im Moment überhaupt
behaupten von diesen wer von diesem
Startschuss in Sachen E-Mobilität
ja was die 2030 Klimaziele betrifft bin
ich nach wie vor leider pessimistisch
dass wir den angesetzten 80 Prozent
Anteil aus Erneuerbaren erzeugen können
das heißt nicht dass wir es nicht weiter
tüchtig versuchen sollen das ist eines
der wichtigsten Ziele für
zukunftsorientierte Wirtschaft
diese Problematik der fehlenden
Rohstoffe und selbst wenn man Zugang hat
der das Rohstoff abbaut und was das mit
der Umwelt tut ist ein ganz wichtiges
Thema und es ist zugleich unsere Chance
können wir uns andere Methoden ausdenken
können wir vielleicht doch auch andere
Arten des motordesigns oder der
batterieherstellung setzen die jetzt
noch nicht gefunden sind meines
Erachtens ist die Chance in dieser
Problematik das ist zeigt wir haben noch
nicht das Endziel das Gleichgewicht
erreicht und die Deutschen haben schon
noch eine Chance damit zu wirken wenn
sie denn auch innovative neue Ideen und
technologische Fortschritte
schauen wir auch mal auf den Bereich
Subventionen die es ja lange gibt und
auch oder lange gab und auch immer noch
gibt und zwar gibt's ja auch einen
Kommentar bei uns im Stream ein User
Userin schreibt wann wird die
Automobilindustrie von Steuergeld wieder
subventioniert wie sehen Sie das denn
also sollten
Subventionen erfolgen um E-Mobilität zu
fördern oder eben nicht
also grundsätzlich sind Subventionen
immer eine Verzerrung der der
marktwirtschaftlichen Kräfte ist wird
immer dazu dass irgendwo Geld
hineinfließt wo es nicht effizient
genutzt wird deswegen stimme ich meinen
Vorrednern da ganz zu dass es jetzt
nicht der Zeitpunkt ist Subvention zu
fördern zu fordern und umzusetzen wir
befinden uns natürlich im Wettbewerb mit
einem Land China das ganz massiv äh
diese
Autos durch Subvention gefördert hat
also wir sind dieser Verzerrung
ausgesetzt meine Hoffnung wäre dass wir
das nutzen um zu sagen na gut dann
orientieren wir uns neu dann finden wir
andere Märkte wo wir Absatz finden
können wo wir nichts einer solchen
Marktverzerrung ausgesetzt sind wie war
die Max schön für den chinesischen Markt
produzieren wie das in ihrem Beitrag
vorhin dargestellt wurde und wir bauen
neuer Handelsbeziehungen auch jetzt
durch Subventionen die Industrie am
Leben zu halten wäre sicherlich der
falsche Schritt wo ähm Staat atlich
Investition manchmal helfen können ist
wenn es darum geht eine neue Industrie
in die Gänge zu bringen also wenn im
Bereich
Batterien oder vielleicht doch grüne
wasserstoffbetreibe ist vielleicht ein
Anstoß war könnte man darüber nachdenken
aber grundsätzlich würde ich sagen wir
müssen jetzt schauen was ist langfristig
gewinnbringend ohne dass es staatlich so
funktioniert wird
sie haben eben gerade angesprochen wir
sind also dieser Verzerrung von dem
subventionierten chinesischen Markt
ausgesetzt es gibt noch eine wichtige
Frage aus dem Stream die ich dazu gerne
noch stellen möchte es gibt da Ideen von
Userin Usern die schreiben was ist mit
Schutzzöllen um den unfairen Wettbewerb
auszugleichen und jemand anders schreibt
auch wir sollten die Einfuhr
chinesischer Fahrzeuge verbieten was
halten Sie davon chinesische Fahrzeuge
mit hohen Strafzöllen zu belegen
ja das ist eine ganz natürliche
menschliche Reaktion ja wenn die mit
unfairen Mitten handeln dann werden wir
uns dagegen und Handeln mit ähnlichen
Mitteln zurück ähm es führt dann zu
einem Subventionswettlauf immer größeren
Verzerrungen und Gelder werden in
Technologien Industrien in Firmen
gesteckt die sich langfristig einfach
nicht auszahlen für das deutsche
Wirtschaftswachstum insofern würde ich
dabei bleiben dass wir uns einfach
darauf fokussieren andere
Handelsbeziehung aufzubauen andere
Märkte zu finden innovativ Fortschritte
zu machen und einfach diesen verzerrten
chinesischen Markt mehr und mehr
beiseite lassen wenn weiter dort mit
solchen Mitteln gearbeitet wird und ganz
zum Schluss noch die Frage für Sie was
wäre konkret eine radikale
Zukunftsorientierung für uns hier in
Deutschland
in Deutschland ist im Augenblick der
Situation ausgesetzt dass die
Energiepreise sehr viel höher sind das
heißt Industrien die Indus traditionell
getragen haben wie zum Beispiel die
Automobilindustrie aber noch stärkere
Maße vielleicht im Maschinenbau und in
der Chemie werden das zumindest mit der
derzeitigen Produktpalette so nicht
können ich habe die Befürchtung dass wir
oft bei solchen großen strukturellen und
wirtschaftlichen Umbrüchen zu sehr auf
die traditionell wichtigen Firmen und
Stimmen hören dass die Regierung das tut
dass wir in der allgemeinen Bevölkerung
das Tun zu mit stattdessen aber mit den
Stimmen zu sprechen mit denen jungen
Leuten der jungen Generation zu sprechen
die neue Ideen hat in der
Umwelttechnologie in den Life seines
oder wo wir nun beim Automobil sind in
alternativen Motoren in Ideen bei
batterienentwicklung Ladestation das
wäre mir sehr wichtig das heißt mehr in
den starterbereich in junge und
operative Unternehmen vielleicht auch
spinos von den traditionellen Autofirmen
wo Ingenieure einfach mal ein paar Jahre
rumtütet ich glaube das brauchen wir und
wir müssen uns einfach klar sein dass da
Dinge verloren gehen werden dass wir
nicht all die Produkte die wir im
Augenblick in Deutschland herstellen und
dem inländischen ausländischen Markt
anbieten im gleichen Volumen haben
werden nur weil er das bereit sind dann
kauf zu nehmen können wir wieder hohe
Wachstumsraten erzählen sagt die
Wirtschaftsweise Frau Professor eure
Gemeinde mit dir vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit heute sehr gerne
also ein Blick in die Zukunft jetzt hier
ganz am Ende ich sehe auch sorgenvolle
Kommentare von Euch Martin Schmidt
schreibt deutsche Zulieferer gehen jetzt
schon rein weil sie pleite und Daniel g
schreibt die technologiewende in der
Automobilindustrie schön und gut aber
wer soll sich in Zukunft bei den
Strompreisen und der Abschaffung des
Verbrenners 2030 noch ein Auto leisten
können das sind natürlich auch alles
Fragen die an dieser Stelle wichtig sind
für heute hier zu diesem Thema aber
jetzt erstmal danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit unsere gute halbe Stunde
ist vorbei habt einen schönen Abend
gerne bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss